Good evening!
As reigning realm champions and, with that,
Eastern Conference champions,
we welcome the representatives from each
of the Eastern playoff Houses,
to the annual Feast of the East,
to kick off this year’s playoffs. So please, feast!
Oh my god, look at this,
there’s like so many wings!
I hope Terrence is happy
I know Dwane Casey was pretty pissed that we took the horse
He scares me. Look at those hands. They're huge!
My mentality is you just gotta take it one game at a time
I mean, I just try to leave 110% on the court
Pass me the pigeon pie!
Hey! ...Hey!
What are you staring at?
Is there a pot of gold behind me?
Is there a shamrock in my teeth?
No, I’m just looking at the second-best team in the East
Oh snap
Big balls for such a small man
...DWARF
Oooh
Yeah, yeah, I’ve heard it all before
He’s too short. He can’t play defense
Hell, he isn’t even the best Isiah Thomas
But somehow, this dwarf’s been scoring 30 points a game,
hitting clutch shots,
and House Celtics owns the No. 1 seed
When this tournament’s over,
you’re all gonna look UP at me,
and you’ll know…
there’s a new King in the East!
This again? Didn’t we do this last year?
We’ve got the chemistry and the defense to take you down
Don’t sleep on the two seed my dear King,
for the North will soon rule the East
We are the New Kings of the East!
This again? Didn’t we do this last year?
60 wins. Count ‘em
It puts us in the one seed, and our house goes 12 men deep
We are the Spurs of the East
Tell ‘em Korverbird
*HAWK SCREECH* TEAM BASKETBALL!
This year, there will be a NEW KING OF THE EAST!
We’re doing this again?
You’re on your last leg, LeBron
We’re coming for you
There will be a new king in the East
And this time I MEAN IT
OK, Paul, you literally did this last year
The era of Paul George,
of Roy Hibbert and House Pacers begins now!
Verticality!
There will be a new KING IN THE EAST!
We’re doing this a--
They say your superteam can’t be beat,
but we got the original Big Three and I say…
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE
KG was wrong
It's not true
Nothing is possible
Th-there's no point in trying
Le-LeBron wins the East every year
We should all be tanking
The playoffs are a trap!
They're gonna beat us all!
It's a trap!
We've gotta get out of here!
GET OUT!
GO TANK!
GO TANK FOR THE FUTURE!